hello everyone I named this video I will
have my revenge for other specific
reason this next game was played on a
tournament in bled 1961
and there you have a very nice Lake and
Bobby was on a small boat with his
friend metria by ELISA and Demetrius
says that Bobby was just staring at the
sky and repeating I will have my revenge
and of course he was talking about
Michael Tao if you've seen in my
previous video in the candidates
tournaments in 1959 two years ago Bobby
lost four games to make us out in row
and he also had one other encounter with
Michael tall in 1960 Olympiad in Leipzig
where he played the first board for the
United States and tall was playing first
board for the Soviets and that game was
drawn so this is a another chance for
Bobby to get his revenge but this isn't
the same Bobby Saul was so used to
playing this is 18 year old Bobby and he
no longer wears his colorful sweater he
now wears an elegant suit there's a
story that Bobby heard that one man in
England has 240 suits and that he is
considered to be the most elegant man in
the world and Bobby said that he would
like to break this record and own even
more than 240 suits and at the time of
this game he had 17 mm Michael Dally's
black so Bobby goes e4 c5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 d4c takes d4 Knight 64 and
now e 6 the diamond of variation of the
Sicilian Knight to c3 Quintus e7 and now
g3 preparing Bishop g2 and in this next
move Tao makes a mistake and if you play
this variation of the Sicilian I'm sure
this happened to you at least once in
your life you have to go a six a six and
Esther Bishop g2 gonna have six but
still played nice we have six maybe he
was daydreaming or something
I don't know how he could miss this and
from this move on
Bobby plays with with with an engine
like precision
so he goes nice to be 5 attacking the
Queen at all goes Queen to be 8 Bishop
to f4 attacking the Queen and here black
can play black and go a 5 here which
leads to a second ago like system but
this was considered to be pretty bad at
the time this game was played so instead
I'll play the Knights to e5 and this is
a disastrous move as the Bobby proves he
plays Bishop to e2 Bishop to c5
Bobby captures Bishop takes on e5 win
take 75 and now F for kicking the Queen
back to be 8 and now he goes e5 and the
problem is this night has nowhere to go
he can go g4 h 5 this is he goes d5 to
losses upon the only place he can go to
is b8 g8 but if you return retrieve your
night to g8 it's like you completed the
game so Tyler is a six and here we have
FX f 6a 6b 5 F takes G 7 Fischer wins
upon here ripped g8 nice to e4 this is
all engine engine moves Bishop to e7
Queen to d4 a rough day for attacking
the Queen and now Knight to f6 check
pinning the king and the rook Bishop
captures Queen captures Queen to c7
Fischer plays long castle rook captures
an a2 King to b1 and rook to a6 and here
a tall could have played Queen to a5 but
it doesn't really matter the Fischer is
Queen to a5 b 3 and this queen is
protecting everything and well with
style doubled pawns he can't really
break this so-called solidus and he
played the rook to a 6
and in this position the engine suggests
Bishop to h5 and this is crushing but
you cannot defend but this is the first
move where Fisher doesn't play by the
engine and I guess he decided if he
already walked four games to McHale tau
this next game he plays against him she
wants the beating in the style of McHale
town itself and here Bobby plays Bishop
takes on b5 at ulta is the rook to b6
Bishop to b3 and stop lazy 5 and this is
the moment where Fischer really goes all
out he plays chess takes e5 sacrificing
his queen Telecasters the queen he takes
on f6
queen goes to c5 and now he captures the
pawn on h7 attacking the rook Queen to
g5 Fischer captures the rook Queen takes
f6 looked at one Queen takes and g7
Bishop captures on SL check King to d8
and our Bishop to e6 pinning the King
Queen to h6 attacking the pawn Bishop
captures Bishop captures and out pinning
the bishop of course Queen captures an
h2 Telecasters Fisher captures the
bishop and now this position is so
completely winning for whites but tau
plays a couple of more moves here we
have some repeating of the position and
here Fischer pushers g4 and the pawn
cannot be taken because if Queen takes
on g4 then simply erupted h1 and this is
winning total wins queen gage 3 g5 Queen
to f3 rook to e1 check into state route
takes on d5 King g7
rook to be six Queen to g3 Ruby one
Queen to c7 roof to d6 going to CH be
three King h7 in the rook to a6 and in
this position without finally resigned
and
Fischer won his first game against the
magician from Riga after this game ended
tall
said in a humorous tone that he learned
this tournament that it indeed was
possible to lose the game against Bobby
and Michael Dahl was watching Mikhail
Botvinnik was watching this game and he
was very satisfied with both of them and
he said that well in the next 15 years
that these two will be fighting for the
throne and he was kind of right Fischer
this go for the throne but to me hotel
well his illness got the better of him
so yeah this is the game this is how
Fischer won his first game against
McHale town I hope you enjoyed it if you
did here on the left you will have two
of my previous videos sorry about that
and you can also check those out so
thank you for your time and feel free to
leave a comment I really enjoy reading
all of your comments and season